welcome back to the rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about what would
happen if Criss Angel could brainwash
the whole world or has he already my
freak which we have seen in the MCU with
Mysterio if you think about it Marvel's
probably most effective villain to date
I'm Erik Bosse here with me is Tommy
Bechtold welcome back buddy
hello I'm just fantasizing fantasy
casting right now a sleight of hand
punk-rock magicians as MCU villains like
David Blaine as bullseye or something
and I think Mysterio as Criss Angel
would be amazing especially with his
slight Lisp and it's weird like kind of
Goffe movements I think that would be
incredible hit me with nothing question
all right you brought up Mysterio so
here is the big question drumroll please
but it is Mysterio actually the most
dangerous and effective villain in the
MCU to date our infinity saga rewatch
has just wrapped and before we move on
to rewatch is of earlier Spider Man
films it's gonna be next up hunter a dog
a very exciting far from home did prove
in my opinion that Mysterio while not
the most cosmically powerful threat is
by far the most effective in the way
that he like permanently except the
heroes world and even scarier ways he
could still hook up everything agreed I
think he was a devastating villain and
also done so well because you liked him
for so long in the movie you're like
this is such an interesting tale yeah
devastatingly charming for sure I wish I
knew had part of the reason Mysterio is
actually so effective is that it's
really a team effort Gyllenhaal was a
big part of it but Quentin Beck invented
the holographic projection tag that Tony
Stark introduced as barf and Civil War
but Beck really combined that tech with
weaponized drones that came from another
ex Stark employee William get to Riva
who's covered a Jeff Bridges spit with a
bunch of scrubs they assembled a team of
experts including people who are great
at screenwriting and wardrobe sleight of
hand gossip I think was one person so
you just told him that Peter Parker was
gonna get the glasses I heard a rumor
that Peters on the rocks with his
now pal she likes to go buy em Oh gossip
Queen what will we do without you
xoxo Gossip we know how it works in this
industry Tommy everything starts with a
rumor hey Tommy I got a gig opening up
for you my friend at W and me said that
they're gonna be casting a Goonies
reboot and you're gonna be great for
Chuck I think I'll go for a Brant do not
give Brolin that role that guy's too
busy he's kind of work no you gotta come
back instead oh s--- I need him I need
more and we should acknowledge at this
tea mysterio while Quentin Beck seems
dead that rest of the team is still
active and still very much around the
world and could do horrible worm yeah
and if anyone could pull off seeming
dead its Mysterio that's kind of his
whole bad right an actor the best actors
Tommy can really fool the whole world
Tom Hanks has so many bodies buried in
his backyard the best thing about being
seen as the nicest guy in Hollywood is
that no one searches my backyard for
bodies actually I think we accidentally
attributed to a conspiracy theory right
now so we might just have to cut that
henry winkler runs so many pyramid
schemes if you go to a party of henry
winkler's house he just sells you avon
and Rodan and fields skincare yeah but
so devastatingly charming the Fonz gets
a no no and even when you know he's got
you you're like ah you know what still
good investment I don't have $3,200 but
I'm gonna write you a check you're just
too good I'm gonna have to wear a tie
maybe not a paper work all right let's
talk about how Quinton Beck's technology
works exactly because there is a lot to
dig into how exactly his words all right
so we use this this fleet of drones and
each drone contains a projector and a
series of weapons it is like sonic shock
wave tank it has like pulse blast it has
like machine-gun fire these drones are
programmed to work together in concert
to end up producing a very realistic
all-encompassing hologram plus the
actual
real-world brick-and-mortar damage to
back it up some people don't know the
difference now it's interesting when
Beck gains access to stark satellite via
Edith that drone fleet gets expanded
they already had some drones now they
have like a ton of drones capable of
being deployed anywhere around the world
cuz you know it's from space they can do
this to conjure an Avengers level threat
that was like their ultimate goal so
they can be the new Avenger right of the
world and gain a monopoly on on terror
or heroism on earth yeah both scary both
now to me one of the drones most lethal
attributes is that they can cloak
themselves to be basically invisible and
unhearable they projected image it seems
like of an empty background space where
they're currently floating seems like
the similar cloaking tech of stealing
Tony's cargo plane and spider-man
homecoming but they're insanely quiet
like real drones those things are loud
as hell you wake up on like a Saturday
morning and someone on the other side of
town is buzzing one of those stupid
things on the day of your Christmas
you're gonna wake up yes yeah and that's
just like little drones like government
drones drones that you know kill people
or lists those things are deafening they
they float real high but if they're on
ground level floating around hallways
and stuff you're kidding you're gonna
hear them they're gonna they're gonna
wake up the neighbors the damn sound
dampening tech they had was you're right
Tommy there must be some kind of like
maybe a noise cancelling frequency that
just like counteracts the sine wave you
know so that like whatever sound it puts
out there's like an inverse sound that
just like neutralizes it that's the only
one is it doesn't make sense otherwise
what's the opposite of a buzz a whisper
you are a sad strange little man and you
have my baby they're just white noise
machines they're floating white noise
machines putting us all to sleep now
there was a crazy subtle line about barb
way back in Civil War that I think does
justify a lot of this crazy logic it's
the way that Tony Stark described the
Bartek by nearly augmented retro framing
or barf god I got to work on that
acronym an extremely costly method of
hijacking the hippo
campus to clear traumatic memories so
barf literally reads our minds the
hippocampus stores memory and that's how
you know tony was using part for that
moment but like also new brain or your
temporal and frontal lobes that deal
with perception how you view the outside
world through the five senses where six
senses in your case Tommy yes that's a
good thought Eric which I just do well
I'm glad you read my mind that moment
cuz many other moments there's some oh
sorry
oh god you shouldn't you shouldn't read
my mind Eric it's going to some dark
places it's in the rabbit hole now it
can't grasp on anything I can't see it I
have to go to my happy but you know we
have landed in the happy place now so
basically in addition to projection barf
can trick your brain into thinking what
you're seeing is real so that kind of
explains why they don't really see
through the smoke screen is it's not
just like what they're seeing it's it's
already in their mind also it's it's a
full package they're getting in this
illusion to augment all this team
Mysterio includes a wardrobe experts
don't discount great wardrobe it makes
all the difference and believability
clothes make the man and there's no such
thing as an empty suit there they have a
set decorator who actually we did
breakdown of this before they designed
that progbar with subliminal messages
all over the walls so there's like
military metals hanging in the
background there's a picture of
sunglasses right over Quinten back
shoulder from peter parker's vantage
point so they're basically like tricking
him into being like oh this trusted
friend is a military hero in his like
fake narrative from his past and he
should be trusted with these classes
they're like brainwashing him in every
possible way they can brainwash them one
of them we also found must be a
sleight-of-hand expert because someone
walks up tells Peter that he dropped his
glasses on the floor he didn't drop
those glasses they pickpocket at him and
made it seem like he's careless and
should not hold onto these glasses to
guilt-trip him into giving them to
Quentin Beck and then there's our good
man gute scooter Minh he's a
screenwriter he's the one who conceived
the whole backstory that really a post
blip Peter Parker and Nick Fury would
believe of like alternate dimensions
crash
into this one they have an expert VFX
team these are like the ultimate
filmmakers and as we saw an inception
that extend a metaphor of a filmmaker
team hacking our dreams
that's essentially what team Mysterio is
and I yeah they can hack my dreams any
night of the week because I have some as
you've seen by reading my mind I've had
some really dark thoughts run through
this noggin
please God me meet you I've been taking
melatonin and I've got to be honest it's
giving me nightmares I think I gotta
stop they did warn me it might work too
well so no more melatonin for this now
we gotta ask what was really going on in
that moment in Berlin and far from home
so Peter gets in a car that's driven by
fury but it's not Nick Fury this is all
part of an illusion Nick Fury's in a
completely different location but he's
sitting inches away from this projection
doesn't sense the fakery who was really
driving that car was was Quentin Beck
driving the car was he droned the car
like just believe me Nick Fury was it
was Elon Musk Tesla technology
self-driving - yeah was it that Elon
Musk would totally be in bed with Queen
oh he was loved and Elon Musk is in the
MCU he had that cameo in Iron Man 2 so
he's around that's true
Dylan musk you do then we'll make it
work
but just to project Nick Fury just think
of the angles they must have had to have
they must have had at least a drone in
the backseat a silent one but like a
drone hovering in front of the car as
they're driving in a drone in the side
window a drone probably behind Peter
like this must have been like
I imagine other Berlin drivers just
looking over on the Autobahn being like
the this is not safe sure I think lots
of drones it's driving next to C car and
that's a Hollywood studio movie just
create a traffic for us I can't drive my
thoughts wagon so fast down the road
with all just Hollywood tomfoolery
everywhere I will write to our
parliamentary Chancellor to change
legislation tell Angela Merkel's will be
no more photo cameras on anymore
cut to a thousand angry YouTube comments
oh you are so on that things have now
become very much like Donkey Kong
we're gonna go got to so many more dark
places with making for the dirtiest you
should be making weird art movies or
well-engineered car but I will could see
it is this construction site that he
takes them to thinking it's like
headquarters that makes sense because
that's just like an empty space they
could use this like a theater
performance space and they could
rehearse and walk everything through
like you know JLo moving the furniture
around and enough to like plant it all
out like kind of like a haunted maze
which is essentially what this is it's a
haunted maze
that they said decorate with projection
by the way I can't believe you just
named checked enough that's a very
important movie I think I haven't seen
in 20 years
my favorite Juliette Lewis Jennifer
Lopez joint of all time for sure so what
we should acknowledge that construction
site fine but this moving car makes no
sense and it just shows how effective
it's freakin crazy
this tech is this is this is like
infinity stone level tech because really
together collectively t Mysterio I would
say our God level illusionists in fact
in our women power ranking episode that
we did a couple months ago I ranked
Mysterio's tech higher than most of the
weapons we've seen the MCU including cap
shield of Black Panthers vibranium
technology and and most of the Tony
Stark mark suits that we've seen over
the years just because if you can pull
the wool over people's eyes you can
accomplish so many things I made it
sound like I have some evil plot but I
scared my involvement in the show now
I'm like what is the end game of this
I've kept you sitting there for 40
minutes and now my goons will have their
way with you editor fade me away into
Sam Jackson or a drone or something do
they do it thanks editor Lex actually
compared Mysterio's tech to other
similar Marvel illusion attacks that
we've seen because he's actually been a
budge the first instance of these
illusion attacks was Scarlet Witch an
age of Ultron so basically she used her
hands - just like spew nightmare imagery
in the Avengers Minds and it paralyzed
them in the middle of those fights each
triggered a traumatic fear or memory
that was specific to them like Tony he
saw aliens attacking earth scaring him
from his you know nightmare after the
first Avengers for cap he was brought
back to that fear of missing out with
Peggy Carter for Thor he was with us as
guardians and Heimdall and like they all
died foreshadowing Ragnarok his deeper
fear for Natasha it was of course the
Red Room appears that will Siri explored
in the new black widow movie
Hulk whatever happened a whole cabin ha
screen we just saw him going berserk and
Johannesburg all pissed off with red
eyes assuming that she put something
they said to piss them off we don't know
exactly what else we're not 100
Sharan what happened he meant to just
say eaten some bad veal or something
yeah he stepped on a splinter something
like that
hulk splinter need tweezers
what are you use like gardening shears
they still don't work now Wanda's
illusions though were temporary they
wore off over time and they were clearly
just like specific memory based
nightmares like I think the Avengers
walked away from that experience knowing
that those were illusions rather than
continuing to question everything in the
reality it's not that effective but
let's compare this to the reality stone
which is a freaking God Rock infinity
stone that was there during the Big Bang
so an infinity or Thanos use this
reality stone to trick that Asgardians
with a smokescreen of nowhere that
wasn't on fire and he conjured a blue
man from Arrested Development a lot of
fun stuff happening and then he ended up
tricky and Gomorrha this is actually a
fun tactic that we learned in a recent
Finity war rewatch he had that dagger
her dagger that he gave her when he had
a sacrifice in her on Vermeer he had it
tucked in his belt really he just did
that to trick him or into thinking she
had a suicide option in case things got
too real but it was never there it was
just bubbles so like she might not have
gone along with him had that dagger not
been in his belt
but it was a really clever form of
brainwashing that he pulled on her he
also used it of course to turn mantis
and ribbons Drax into cubes he turns
Peter Quill's blaster fire also into
bubbles a lot of bubbles going on here a
lot of big bubble fetish guy he loves
love's big bathtubs I've gone to his pay
his only fans it's all Haven a bathtub
now I'm Titan he used the reality stone
as like a PowerPoint slide show like the
show is planets path and then he uses it
and the wizard duel against Doctor
Strange he manipulates the ground
beneath strained his feet to like drag
him in I thought that was kind of cool
but again yep they're all d stones kind
of a Wimpy stone its effects are
temporary when Dan is least know where
Drax and mantis just come back together
happen and then in terms of overall
damage I would rank that reality stone
as the least destructive infinity stone
I mean even the soul stone which he we
rarely see him actually used that
requires a blood sacrifice to attain it
at least the reality stone was an angry
sledge in the dark world and then
stopped being that effective at that
point right now we should talk about
Loki the god of mischief he also has the
power to conjure false projections but
really in the MCU it seems confined to
his own form like
copies of himself he can disguise
himself as other people we can put
himself somewhere else it's kind of like
I'm over here actually like misdirection
but not like creating big illusions that
everyone is trying out now dr. strange
technically has the power to create
illusions he did hide the time stone by
disguising it as a star in the
background in that battle infinity war
and there was a deleted scene that the
writers wrote out that would have shown
him trapping Thanos in this trial
illusion where the Living Tribunal would
have judged him as guilty that didn't
end up make it in the film of course but
really I would say Strange's more
interested in other spells or like
teleport actually teleporting his
enemies to other alternate dimensions
like the mirror dimension he doesn't
have time to do illusions he's an actual
sorcerer he's not gonna be a Criss Angel
level illusionist bringing it all the
way back to the beginning he's not doing
magic for humans he's doing I'm gonna
put half of your body in another realm
and the other half here and cut you in
half the teleportation he should be
doing so much more amputation like wrong
uses the portal to cut off call obsidian
arm yeah that needs to happen constantly
should I use that I Thanos his arm to
get the gauntlet interdimensional buzz
saws they should they should just be
mowing people in half yeah that should
be happening constantly agreed now
another example of like illusions and
brainwashing that's happening the Kree
supreme intelligence and Captain Marvel
actually did implant false memories to
Gaslight Carol Danvers into thinking the
Skrull were behind the bad things that
happened to her instead of the Kree
doing it to her kind of like in that
black mirror episode I think in season 3
or see zap or can't remember it
reprograms its soldiers into seeing the
scroll as these beastly monsters if they
have to like mow down but really the
scroll are actually not that bad they're
like refugees I would say this is an
example of one of the subtle but lasting
illusions in the MCU and it's very
dangerous it's like a good cautionary
tale to see what happens to like an
advanced alien race that decides it
wants to like control the minds of its
people now shifted over to the Marvel
Comics very briefly here there are
mutants of course like Jean Grey Charles
Xavier who can work people's realities
to create telepathic illusions but
really I think those who use their
powers to like influence thoughts and a
bit of mind control but they try to help
people get to their own conclusions and
just star in amis in there
cracks there is a mutant illusionist
called mastermind from the Hellfire Club
that's Jason wind grade he actually
inspired the character Jason Stryker
remember annex 2 that's been united yes
so he that was strikers son in that
movie but he used an illusion to trick
Professor X into weaponized and cerebro
and then you know magneto took control
the situation and use them to weaponize
it and reverse it so that it targeted
you know non mutants humans so we did
see a bit of this illusion stuff and we
have yet to see whether that x-men
timeline is in soon canon there's a
couple theories out there we don't know
god I hope it is I need Logan Roy to be
to be William strike ah-oh everyone
gather round gather round I'm going to
announce who's going to be the next head
of the army it's me just like Peter
Parker and happy Hogan playing ball on
the floor cue that like amazing piano
riff oh my god someone internet get on
this make a super cut of the eye of a
seed from XD with succession music god I
beg of you we will need to go to the
internet we can make our editors do it
editor please now did they do it thanks
editor we don't realize but in another
timeline five hours from now John
shaking his head cursing or pouring a
heavy ones like long night Rita
Wednesday's say those words
now this brings up the question of what
worse things could Mysterio still do
because as I said team Mysterio is still
active William Kent Arriva downloaded
this file and he presented doctored
footage to Jay jonah Jameson to
discredit Peter Parker and really in
doing so he launched a very powerful
fake news network in the MCU I don't
like a button chemicals in the water
stick turn the friggin frogs gay and as
they put out quit to make might still be
alive
because Peter did not ask eat it
specifically if Beck was dead he's real
[Music]
yeah and that did not answer the
question but all illusions are down
doesn't tell us that Beck is like
[ __ ] himself on that bridge commits
to the role of corpse
you know you gotta take a pulse
you gotta give it a big sniff that's
right big stick Wow Mysterio if you've
read every Marvel comic you know mister
has done all kinds of crazy stuff all
kinds of crazy illusions like trapping
people in toy boxes and and all kinda
crazy special effects but in the old man
Logan comic Mysterio reaches his darkest
depths because that set an alternate
reality it's a post-apocalyptic future
in which Mysterio has in the back story
of this storyline has tricked Wolverine
into killing the x-men by making the
x-men look and sound and even smell like
enemies to old man Logan and he killed
them all and it's tragic
it makes Logan feel suicidal he tries to
lay on the train track let a freight
train hit him it doesn't work it's
horrible and then you know the Marvel
villains take over the world now the
movie Logan actually hints at a similar
Westchester incident but we find out
that was like Charles Xavier Zone
telepathic seizure then end up killing
all the mutants and Logan was the only
one who could survive it so using this I
think we can conclude that the worst
thing that team Mysterio could do in
this MCU is turn the Avengers and the
other MCU heroes against each other kind
of like Zemo did in civil war but even
more effectively like imagine Scarlet
Witch Doctor Strange thinking their
enemies like
Scarlet Witch things said visions death
or Quicksilver death might have been
preventable if dr. strange did something
about it and those two crazy sorcerers
they could level a city imagine if he
tricks Hulk into thinking like there's a
threat in Wakanda if hope just goes
around smashing Wakanda
now they knows where it is that's
terrifying imagine if he brainwashes
Thor into thinking a bunch of frost
giants have taken over Midland High
School directs Peter Parker's High
School in Queens and Peter Parker's
house trying to keep him from killing
kids in the gymnasium because Thor
thinks they're elves it's terrabyte
really they could build an entire world
based on lies and deception they can
brainwash all of our society the way the
Kree are brainwashed but earth is filled
with Avengers I don't know though are
people really gonna believe the
malevolent man could really brainwash an
entire society of people I don't know
that seems a little too far-fetched but
again I don't think Americans will go
for that at all yeah luckily we're
taping this episode in in the good time
who knows what happens when that
alternate earth diverged around 2011 or
whatever that happens true
cut that out John - political so in
conclusion Tommy I think we can conclude
that Mysterio got in that heroes heads
more than any other MCU villain he was
able to fool Nick Fury that's crazy that
to me is that that's the checkmate move
right there and you can say oh it wasn't
Nick Fury it was a Skrull but like Nick
Fury signed off on Talos filling in for
him in this assignment yeah I don't
think he had no idea that Mysterio
existed and it was his operation still
really only Thanos has haunted an
Avenger this much but Thanos his damage
is mostly undone like there are other
you know effects of the blip but mostly
it's not that bad Mysterio has like told
everyone you can't trust anything and
also anyone can pick up that torch like
we have most of the members of team
Mysterio
but like anybody can fill that role if
they just know to use the tech any good
actor can just like pick up that weapon
Peter Parker's exposed that was like his
most precious thing he was really the
only main MCU here who had his secret
identity now he doesn't have that
anymore no one trusts him no one
believes anything and I think that's
leaves MCU in its most dangerous state
going forward that we've ever seen
before
so Mysterio is a piece of [ __ ] yeah
before we move on to some bite-sized
questions that Tommy is actually gonna
answer for us we want to give it quick
thank you to our sponsor expressvpn
sometimes our online research to new
rock stars videos takes us into some
really really dark places the rabbit
holes go in many different directions
made some videos questioning hoax sexual
life and I'm not happy with the
recommendations I now get on YouTube as
a result of the internet keeping track
of my search history oh boy it's times
like these when it doesn't really matter
what mode you use or how many times you
clear your browsing history your
internet service provider can still see
every site you visited and that is why
whether at home or at work we use
Express VPN expressvpn is an app that
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure servers so that
your isp can't see the sites you visit
they start sleeping in keeps all of your
information secure by encrypting a
hundred percent of your data with the
most powerful encryption available it
runs seamlessly in the background just
tap one button and you are protected
experts
is available on all your devices phones
computers even your smart TV so there's
no excuse for you to not be using it if
you visit our special link right now at
expressvpn comm slash big queue you can
get an extra three months of express to
be in for free support the show watch
what you want and protect yourself with
expressvpn at expressvpn comm slash big
queue
God knows I do and Eric and when you're
a man like me you'd be a fool not to
protect your searches alright let's move
on to a few bite-sized questions that
Tommy is gonna take over for us Tommy
you ready I'm ready
hit me our friend cracked checkol on
discord asked if Peter Parker had taken
his iron spider suit on his trip and far
from home would that suit have detected
the drones and illusions very good
question I do a little research here now
we know that Mysterio uses his own drone
previous to acquiring the Edythe
technology and Peter is unable to to
detect those once they do acquire the
the Edith Technology and the start drugs
it's on a new operating system so we
don't know that the iron spider suit has
been updated yet to to be able to have
that type of detection and and also one
of the reasons that Peter has trouble
detecting drones is because his if you
remember his spider sense is still
weakened from the blip or the smell
right yeah yes still suffering from all
that PTSD Aunt May is actually able to
hit him with a banana he's not firing on
all cylinders and so you really don't
see him get his full spider sense and
powers back until the final battle with
Mysterio so I guess the answer I have
for this question which is a really fun
question is a big fat maybe well that's
that's a very good point cuz you gotta
think T Mysterio probably planned out
Peters whole trip and they would not
have done that assuming that he just
would decide not to bring his iron
spider suit they must have like
accounted for that their drones are in a
separate operating system and it wasn't
until london where they had all of these
stark linked drones you're right and I
think the X Factor again is just the
fact that he did his spider sense wasn't
he wasn't full strength spider-man all
right next question not that Brandon
Clarke on Twitter
actually asked me this recently but I
think we should dig more into it has a
movie ever switch Directors in the
middle production but still turned out
good I'm assuming he's talking about
like the switch from a sacs nitrogen
Joss Whedon in the Snyder Justice League
movie yes great question I know you
answered some already Eric I did a
little bit of a deep dive and there's
actually a pretty big precedent for
these things being successful actually
there are three different Pixar movies
that all change directors within a year
of their released as you know Pixar
movies take you know three to four years
sometimes even more brave ratatouille
and the good dinosaur and well the good
dinosaur is not considered a mega hit
it's still made over 300 million dollars
all change directors within the final
year of production and that's just
animation live-action we've got
Spartacus replaced Anthony Mann with
Stanley Kubrick and although there's a
lot of problems with Spartacus watch any
award show and they seem to show clips
from Spartacus an awful lot so yeah
that's a Kubrick movie The Outlaw Josey
Wales famously directed by Clint
Eastwood was in production for a couple
weeks with another director named Phil
Kaufman before Clint decided to take
over and direct it and a lot of people
think that relaunched the Clint Eastwood
actor / director dynamic yeah a side
note Henry Winkler was replaced three
weeks into shooting of Turner and hooch
which is the reason why ironically there
is a strange Tom Hanks Henry Winkler
beef what no the two most loved men in
Hollywood allegedly don't really like
each other I didn't know that yeah isn't
that crazy like I mean though it kind of
makes sense like the two people that
everyone likes they got it like they got
it dislike someone no one searches my
backyard for bored
finally if you'll allow me to bend the
rules to be the mother of all examples
of this is named dick Richards was hired
to produce a movie about a murderous
shark terrorizing a small village off
the coast of Long Island and he kept
rolling the producers by referring to
the shark as a whale and pretending he
was confused about the point of the
movie he did not want to direct it so
they replaced him with a man named
Steven Spielberg and we got the movie
Jaws to see him before
you go swimming now cameras had it
technically rolled yet but the movie was
well into pre-production before Steven
Spielberg took over then they had
another extended pre-production where
they you know improved on things and
Steven very famously with his team
created Bruce the mechanical shark and
we now have jaws so that one's a little
bit more of a stretch but I think
there's plenty more movies that you know
we probably don't even realize how to
director for a week right and you know
obviously you know when it goes horribly
wrong
you probably rarely hear what it goes
right yeah exactly and I think that's
the point the modern era has publicized
all this stuff because you know social
media people have special access you
have things like deadlines and TMZ that
has like special access to behind the
scenes right now we didn't have in like
the old era of cinema your average
person probably wouldn't care in 1975 as
long as it's playing on Friday night
they're probably gonna see yeah I
probably could care less but now we're
information is such a commodity right
you're totally right and that's like one
thing we get we got to keep in mind
there's a lot more going on behind the
scenes that you know we'll just never
know like you mentioned Spielberg with
jaws there's a whole thing where
Spielberg shot ET and he really did
direct poltergeist at the same time but
because of DGA and studio rules he like
they had to accredit to that other
director of that director i said like
this field work shot most of this movie
with spielberg shot Schindler's List he
did some of the principal production but
like a second unit director shot most of
Jurassic Park two movies that were shot
pretty much in the same year around the
same time rez as soon as this drastic
park so like there's a lot going on
behind the scenes it doesn't matter
like the story behind these movies does
not it affects our view of the creative
result way too much and right and people
go into movies already hating it because
they hated the process that went on
behind the scenes alright we have time
for one more question we're gonna pull
this from the mailbag the box of mail
shame and our question this week is are
on our golden ticket have you ever been
part of or felt you were part of a cult
alright
yes well Eric you and I
both were at the IO West in Hollywood
for many yeah that was very cult-like
ended at just the right time because now
every existing Improv Theater is being
torn down for all of their skeletons in
their closet for birth your two bodies
exactly we got out of the game two years
earlier don't we look like woke pioneers
now anyway I have two different times in
my life felt like I was part of a cult
organization one when I was in college I
joined a fraternity oh and this felt to
me fine
at the time but looking back there were
certain things where it was like oh
there was really a lot of like
obligatory engagement on my end and like
taking myself away from other social
groups and friends and dedicating all of
my time to this fraternity now like most
cults there were the seductive elements
of frat parties and tons of drinking and
the reason I put this as my 1a is
because ultimately I would say 80% of my
friend we're in it to party as much as
possible I kind of hang out and play
video games and there were 20% that
we're like new all of the founders knew
all the codes knew like the songs and
everything and so that to me was more of
a fret that I could get every cult that
I could could get down with however the
true cult experience in my life was
playing for a fairly fairly successful
football program in high school that we
were really really good we didn't lose a
lot of games the varsity teams ahead of
me had won state championships at the
triple-a level which is the biggest
schools playing against yeah competitive
schools so that experience to me was
more cult-like because if you had anyone
in your life suggest that the football
team was not the most important thing in
your life the people on the team
including the coaches would vilify that
person for saying that to my team my
rules you don't like it don't let the
door be on the way out
there's always this thing where coaches
will say the you know family comes first
you know school comes second then
football but in reality and on that team
football came first and if he made any
excuses you were ostracized now I was
not super super good at football so I
didn't get to to beat up when I
eventually quit the team in my senior
year of high school my brother was a
star on the team oh wow he quit he just
hated football he loves you know he
liked watching he didn't like playing
and you needed like the violent contact
when he quit
they were merciless to him they like
terrorized him through the halls his
friends were not allowed to be his
friends anymore I mean it was truly
crazy
and so I'd know many of you have noticed
that I have this big bald patch in the
center of my face and you comment about
it on the YouTube videos this was from a
football helmet going directly on my
face in a football game once so that's
why I don't have hair there I have
answered that in a couple of comments so
that was one gift I got for joining the
cult was you know my jaw broken by a
football it's holy [ __ ]
you still have the scars from this
experience the battle scars but a lot of
fun and you know you got to hold hands
with the cheerleaders when you walk
for me it's a toss-up merciless bullying
hand-holding of cheerleaders so you take
the good you take the bad add them up
what do you have football how about you
Eric
any Colts for you yeah some cult-like
experiences you mentioned improv and
yeah definitely our improv experience if
there were any more money being made
from this at least that I owe I mean
used to be a second city there there is
money being made there so you can call
those Colts but in college yeah I mean
our Improv Club had like a hundred
people in it it was very Freddie and
while it was not itself a cult because
there was never a figurehead in it you
know it's College so a people are always
cycling in and out there was definitely
some cult-like behavior in that yeah
there was a lot of that exclusionary
suppressive person exclusion we're like
oh they're not really committed so
you're not allowed to affiliate with
them anymore there was a lot of just
like drama but I mean every club is
drama but there was one specific like
kind of cult moment where like there was
a guy who we kind of like brought up in
the club who we thought was a nicest guy
in the world and he was always like
helpful he's always like showing up to
stuff helping us like build props and
sets we talked to other like newer
people in club be like yeah that guy's
an [ __ ] he's so mean to us we
realized he on our behalf was like being
so shitty to everyone underneath but
that's like a big thing in cults like
you have the middle man right who's like
worships the cult leader but then it
terrorizes everyone else like as like as
their attack dog so anyway but but that
wasn't so much of a cult the creepy cult
experience it's like I grew up Catholic
and I'm not saying all religions or
Colts but my family was really involved
in our church and I would do the
readings sometimes it's like a youth
Lecter I think they called him and so I
would do like the first reading of the
second reading because my dad was really
involved with that
he still is but after a church service
one time a guy who I just knew from
around the church pulled me aside he
goes hey you're a really good speaker
you should come to our prayer group
tonight and I'd love for you to speak
about what it means to be like a
teenager and and having the faith and
I'm like yeah sure these guys I see them
around church all the time they're
they're important leaders so I had my
mom drive me back to the the parish
center afterwards and and she's like
what is this I'm like no it's it's like
part of this and
or group but I go in there and it's a
real off-the-books thing like they are
not an organized group it was just like
15 dudes who are all in their 40s or 50s
and they're saying prayers and singing a
lot of there's a lot of songs that's I
know it was like a little cult II it's
just a lot of songs yeah I'm like what
is the structure of this there's singing
songs that aren't like in any of the
hymnals people are crying yeah yeah it
was really uncomfortable and they had me
speak it's like and then something like
two hours and they had me speak at like
an hour 50 minutes in so I'm sitting
there the whole time and people are like
hugging me it's like more like a support
group but I don't really know exactly
what it's about it's just like an off
the book Church men's group and then I
do my little speech it's just kind of
like a semi improvised thing about like
oh I'm going to public school next year
but I want to continue to be a good
Catholic and then at the end they were
so impressed with my speech well I'll
never forget one of them looks at me he
goes wow I mean y'all I feel like I'm
looking at the next president of the
United States 14 that is someone's like
Jojo future president he's like yeah
future president whatever whatever right
now we could run him he'll be our boy
king he'll change this world he'll give
us our gilead oh hello our beautiful
blonde boy King face let's sing that
would have been a familiar tune yeah
you're nothing I I hadn't heard any of
these songs before some of it was in
different languages that were not
languages I'd heard and afterwards my
mom was in the parking lot was so pissed
off she had stayed the whole time I
thought it's gonna be like 15 minutes
she sat in the car the whole time she
goes what the hell was that and I'm like
I don't know and I'm like I was it I
could forget the name of the group but
she's like that's not a real group
that's they aren't like an affiliated
group with the church is just a bunch of
dudes who found an empty room at the
church every Sunday night and you got
sucked in right you're never going back
there no so that was my cult experience
and I did go back the next Sunday in the
room was empty but some
times at church I would see some of them
and they would give me a weird handshake
and a weird nod and they had like these
uses on their eyes so I'm still a member
of it and I've got to go speak there
tonight because I'm gonna be the next
person in the United States
all hail president boss well that is our
show reminder that you can join our
official discord by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash and rock stars didn't
get an audio version of the show by
subscribing a new rock stars big
question wherever your podcast Tommy
thank you so much for joining us this
week thanks for having me I can't wait
to go to a barber and trim my eyebrows
which I am currently realizing are they
are curled up like the people in dune
[Music]
it's getting kind of bad over here you
kind of like the the gatekeeper of Oz
like who rang that Bell exactly well
pray for me everyone pray for me as much
as you can thank you and thanks to
everyone who submitted questions on
Twitter and on discord and if you use
Twitter use the hashtag big question to
get our attention you can also mail us
at our Pew box but really discord is the
fastest way we see these questions so
become a patron join our discord and
Wilson will see your questions you'll
gets preferential treatment because
you're helping keep this general life
but you can follow me at a boss you can
follow Tommy and Tommy back told on all
social media and you can follow a new
rock stars and socials of course
subscribe here on YouTube to get to boot
information all those if you care about
see you all next week
thanks I
[Music]